[Music]
hey guys so today I'm back playing
another horror game for you
it's called wick a lot of people have
played this game before but I personally
have no clue what it's about I just know
it's supposed to be really scary because
as per usual I try not to watch other
horror games because I don't want to
spoil it for when I play it for you guys
so yeah this I'm gonna be horrible at
this no no I'm fine
teenagers enter woods one is blindfolded
they're playing wick what is wick
claimed missing children haunt the woods
and can be seen by candlelight playing
missing children haunt the woods claim
is it claimed like that doesn't make
sense whatever what a teenager's play
the stupidest games yeah I've heard the
story no it's true it was a long time
ago the house burned down the parents
died with their kids bodies I stopped
you're creeping me out
don't worry I'll protect you I'm serious
those kids used to play in these woods
but one by one they disappeared he
pleased to come up here and leave stuff
in case the kids were still alive they
left candles burning but the candles
moved in the night nobody would let
their kids come up here after that he
didn't just skip town or something don't
tell me you're buying this no I know one
of the kids he was with they were up
here playing wick Tyrael would you calm
down what was that someone's out there
we go back Knights please don't take the
blindfold off until we're gone
good luck see you at 6:00 a.m. if you
live
is it the scared girl that's blindfolded
because that's really me she does not
seem like she wanted to be there
teenagers leave friend blindfolded and
locked the gate they plan to return at 6
a.m.
wait what is it like midnight they can
leave her there just six hours what does
she needs the toilet yeah it is midnight
they just killed me they're rubbish
friends I think she needs to find a new
set of friends here's a candle that's
nice
alright something weird on that tree yo
I got a nice candle it burns right it's
so nice do I pick it up is it like
Slenderman stay in the light ok am I
looking for notes is it like the
Slenderman game can I run with the shift
key yeah it's just like Slenderman what
is that don't think run that's cool I
don't really want to think anyway
because if I think I get scared
why is she covering the candle does it
go off if I run too much I don't know I
can't run because I'm holding a candle
wait which way do I go
which wait wait wait wait I lost the
path am I gonna die already I'm gonna
die already on oh his path okay oh look
it's a house let's go this way
cuz it's a house and houses they usually
that good part from this one cuz it
cries
and it has magician chairs what the hell
how did that chair okay whatever I'm
gonna ask weird questions I thought I'd
find another little candle in there
obviously not just find a weird
disappearing chair what is the point of
this oh I forgot there's like no point
in horror games okay um I think I'm
supposed to find another candle because
mine is running out but I don't think
I'm gonna find another candle because I
think I just went in a huge circle and I
have a feeling that well then the AG man
you lasted a whole round to try and find
more than one candle this time yeah that
we get let's go right this time that's
gonna bright this time damn dirty the
menu is funky I don't want no I don't
need this I didn't even get to a safe
point are there safe points in this game
or is it more like Slenderman I don't
know you guys can answer my questions
later on please I would be very grateful
if you answer my questions because I
have many because oh I thought that tree
had blood on it yeah cuz I have a lot of
questions I don't
understand what I'm doing and I'm sure
you all know more than me because you
always do my footprints stop it stop it
stop it stop it stop it
sorry when you wear headphones not good
I can hear things walk in that isn't my
walking I can't even speak properly I
can hear things walking that stop my
walking but it's okay it's gonna I'm
following a path that seems to leave me
now with it just to me it's a while as
well and I found a chocolate bunny no I
want the bunny nah this makes me uneasy
don't I love dogs
yeah steward dogs I can do it don't I
can I sort lips of some [ __ ] f F oh oh
hello
thank you hello
what is this the language of fear I am
fluent are you
okay ah-ah-ah how many matches ever got
wait how do I do that
leave me alone I never did anything to
you
apart from intruder woods but I'm just
trying to help I should have bought
candy I can't see anything
where is these other matches that are
supposed to be let's just run and hope
that we can look or something
nope nope I literally can't see anything
I think I'm going around in circles I
post first we'll be okay
camp this way let's go to account come
on kids let's go to camp
Oh shite alight what that's even my
language why did I say that yeah okay
it's gonna wear off soon you're not even
gonna scare me anymore
oh yeah the match oh [ __ ]
I've only got too much Shinzon haft I
keep on seeing these glints and I go
towards them and it's nothing and I
think that it's gonna be a candle sealer
glints there they are I think it's gonna
be a candle but it's not oh my God thank
you thank you thank you thank you how do
i light it though oh that was my last
match shite okay I'll stop
I have no idea what I'm doing I feel
like I'm walking around in circles and I
probably am go away no one likes you I'm
not gonna play with you I'm going this
way actually ha ha ha where am I going
I'm under a bridge I'm a troll
[Music]
let's go on top of the bridge no stop it
yes but f to transfer the flame site and
I didn't transfer the flame whatever
okay I remember there's about quarter of
a candle left on the bridge but I you
know I'm probably gonna forget where the
bridge is anyway so that's fine cool
cool I think I saw something over here
there's things and finding things and
stuff
hello what's this another candle oh man
it's for in the bandages come off
all right creepy muck creeps in' dammit
I did it again no boom I gotta go
alright hello see what I don't need the
candles they're everywhere and now I
know all right can I get through this
gate hello
no hey I think I was here a second ago
was a night and I just walked right past
to handle
whatever where was that kind of I see
two shiny things
oh they are candles on they are fine
screw you don't need you in my life
[Music]
nothing in that house hey oh okay no
gotta be on the ball ah rival proper
guys who feel someone actually lives up
there would be like a thousand years old
here's two bucks for a new padlock can I
go now archives of your old pioneer site
within woods homestead burned down in
1924 family listed as dead but
children's bodies never located field
officer interviews local resident news
archives three and focus so the
photographs are and don't don't even
let's just carry him so much fail right
okay
let's the coyote on what's this this is
a cool oh I love fat that's this is an
amazing drawing I like little creepy
drawings like that that's what I do and
I'm bored like a little emo child hey
this way okay I get it now the glist
no I'm not scared I'm not scared
um I forgot what I was saying I think I
was saying that the glints yeah the
glimpse of candles and I know that now
because I'm like crunch stop it I'm not
scared of you
where's the glints gone whereas the
glints gone oh I think I walk past it
it's gonna be behind me no it's not good
hey where's a glimpse gone
whoa whoa what did they just teleport me
they teleport me thanks though because I
haven't been here yet so this is
interesting I think we've got a candle
up here yes we is there anything here
Tim Tim it Timothy and Lillian sitting
in the tree David it shouldn't be okay
that was not fair you're waiting for me
that wasn't fair in the slightest
shall we see if we can at least get to 2
a.m. before I freak out I think I'm
doing pretty well for my fresco come on
1 a.m. let's let me get the tool
although I hardly don't even know what
I'm doing but you do this which way did
I go last night the one that says fellow
are the glutes the glutes are the
candles and that's the way that boom
wanna go
Oh what do you think in my owl
impression
could we just climb a tree sorry I was
not expecting that I was just gonna say
blend in with the elves but obviously no
I don't think don't think it would be
very safe to climb a tree when they
could just pop out at you at any time
and then you could just fall and die
don't know where I'm going oh here we go
by this clint over here let's follow
follow the cliff this includes it
there's - clintus Mentos mint that's
good hello candle I think I press F to
switch switch room yes hey I don't like
oh my what the hell
huh
these kids are not happy what's the
story behind this case not a spoiler
three no spoilers
what's the hell don't do that to my
candle what oh she can obviously vit
it's not very polite I don't even care
about finding things I just wanna I just
want to survive this is just a story of
survival shy take away okay
I don't mind it when you do that that's
fine and that's I was like about to pick
up a candle that would be so annoying
guys oh okay
whatever that was false false alarm
false alarm false happiness okay so for
the glint slipped the glint stick to the
clicker Kaitlyn's
can you see them no but I can hear the
things go away I don't want to play with
you ever
I really have no idea where any other
candles are and I'm ready I'm going I'm
getting worried Oh bulls I'd be okay if
she teleported me I'm fine with that
don't do nur Dan I just had to pass
again oh look at the cans stop stop it
stop it don't cry on me girly not your
mum Oh God
but okay I know this one up on this up
on this bridge Oh bull why did I do that
oh what's this
oh it found something pick it off then
okay oh go away I don't care
come on pick it up pick up the candle
and then light it and then we can run I
don't know why when Irish that I'm sorry
to every Irish person that was funnier I
keep going around in circles
I think no don't say yak man don't say
it it would help if there was a map of
some sorts oh we found a graveyard oh
god don't do it not here not in the
graveyard
yeah idiot I got some evidence you're
gonna get me I'm gonna run like Sonic
okay but might we're not candles and
that would be bad Oh what the bloody
hell why did you do that
why go that way do game play right okay
don't linger in here you know what
happened last time
out she's everywhere
she is my worst nightmare okay good
it's carry on going this way cuz I don't
think we've been this way properly deep
whenever I find a new area I can't
explore it because something happens I'm
backed up into a corner this is not not
just keep on running I think you can
make it and do their ass oh my god
bye it's dark it's extremely dark and I
cannot thank you I think we were on our
way back home and we totally heard
someone totally like somebody's sleeping
snoring like a mother trucker
matichek local campus report sounds of
someone sleeping and loud snoring
suggests subject was still alive and
present in woods at the time area month
entered into evidence wait do we have a
map you telling me there's a map where
is the map cool okay
let's have a look at the news the new
drawing it's not gonna be cool
oh it is cool very very cool
I really appreciate these drawings I'm
like it's not gonna be his cause the
last drawing but it was just so cool oh
look there's another one the UFO no
don't wake him oh who is it it's like a
Snorlax all right okay let's go all
right
I already saw a glint this is good we
are on the right tracks enjoy this this
is a brilliant game I'm not gonna listen
to the dog being hurt because that's
horrible
I don't like that sound of course it's
only the it's only their truck I'm so
surprised that there was nothing nothing
in the house oh there's no candle here
no I think they change they must change
position now I'm good I don't want to
listen to your whisperings Oh what's
this we found a watchtower that's
interesting can we go in up the
watchtower
don't start chasing me because I want to
have a look around I want to enjoy the
scenery and I can't do that if you're
trying to freak me out now that's
nothing here fine oh oh here we go
[Music]
can I jump now I gotcha
oh stop I think as soon as one thing
finishes another one starts
that I did not enjoy did not enjoy that
oh I thought wait what why did I just do
that okay no idea hey why is she taking
so long
pick it up turn around get oh he locked
me in how do I get back out no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no let me out
let me out I think that's enough for now
we can have a look we can have a look at
our findings
but that's definitely enough for tonight
listen look at the awesome drawings this
is the first room was like yeah it was
all right
and then it just got better from there
those hands ammonia ferngully
you know the creepy the creepy hands I
hope you guys watch the frame girlie
this is cool stay away from her that's
really really cool
also every kind of like Emily wants to
play where's this new new people that
come up at every hour whatever because I
remember seeing bunny girl she killed me
last time oh this guy I know him me and
him are on terms did I wake this guy
then is that he was like in front of me
it's gonna be doesn't even look like a
person there actually looks like a
Snorlax it's round-bellied oh no that
one him okay so I just have to look away
from him and if I see us know likes
don't wake it
he was the ah-1 hope you guys enjoyed
that thanks for watching another episode
of Wimpy girl plays I don't think I
disappointed you did I was I was pretty
wimpy this episode give this a thumbs up
if you want to see another episode we
played and of course if you enjoyed
watching me screaming
have a little bit everything oh you
still I mean
[Music]